How old were you when you first came out?
你第一次出柜时多大？
[LAUGHS] That's weird to say it like that.
[笑] 这样说感觉很奇怪。
I know.
我知道。
I can't really talk about it.
我真的没法谈论它。
Yeah, why is that weird? It does seem weird  to me too.
是啊，为什么会觉得奇怪？对我来说这似乎也挺奇怪的。
Well, because it feels-- to me, it feels--
嗯，因为感觉——对我来说，感觉——
OK, here's something that I just heard about, though I guess it's been out there for a little while now. It's the idea that fat people would come out to their friends and family as fat. Like, they would decide, OK, today's the day, going to say it out loud to people, I'm fat.
好的，这里有一件事我刚听说，虽然我觉得它已经出现有一阵子了。这是一个观点，即胖子会向他们的朋友和家人出柜，承认自己是胖子。就像是，他们会决定，好吧，今天就是这一天，要大声对人们说出来，我很胖。
I heard about this from Lindy West. She's a writer who's been on our program before. Maybe you remember her story about confronting an internet troll.
我是从琳迪·韦斯特那里听说的。她是一位作家，之前上过我们的节目。也许你还记得她关于面对网络喷子的故事。
Coming out as fat is a strange idea, because, of course, people can see if you're fat. It's no secret. It's not like when you come out as gay or transgender. Nobody says to you, dude, I can't believe you're fat. Lindy says it was obvious how big she was.
以胖子的身份出柜是一个奇怪的概念，因为，当然，人们能看到你是否肥胖。这不是什么秘密。这不像当你以同性恋或跨性别身份出柜那样。没人会对你说，伙计，我不敢相信你是个胖子。琳迪说，她有多胖是很明显的。
But I always felt like if I didn't mention it that maybe people wouldn't notice. Or it could just be this sort of polite secret, like, open secret that we didn't address, because it felt so shameful. It just felt impolite to talk about, like me not wanting to burden you with my failure.
但我总觉得如果我不提它，也许人们就不会注意到。或者它可能只是某种礼貌上的秘密，比如，我们没有谈论的公开秘密，因为它让人感到太羞耻了。谈论它让人觉得很不礼貌，就像我不想用我的失败来拖累你一样。
Like, I'm not going to bother you with this.
比如，我不会用这个来打扰你。
Yeah, and just give me a little more time. Let's not talk about it, and I promise I'll fix it.
是的，再给我一点时间。我们别谈这个了，我保证我会改掉的。
That's key, she says. As long as you're a fat person who's trying not to be fat, that's acceptable. That's a good fat person. You don't totally admit to yourself you're fat, because, well--
她说，这才是关键。只要你是一个试图不再变胖的胖子，那是可以接受的。那是一个“好”胖子。你没有完全对自己承认你很胖，因为，嗯——
The way that we are taught to think about fatness is that fat is not a permanent state. You're just a thin person who's failing consistently for your whole life.
我们被教导看待肥胖的方式是，胖不是一种永久的状态。你只是一个一直在生活中不断失败的瘦子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So to actually say, OK, I am fat-- and I have been as long as I can remember, so I don't know why I live in this imaginary future where I, you know, someday I'm going to be thin.
所以真的要说，好吧，我就是胖——而且我记得我一直都很胖，所以我不知道为什么我活在一个虚构的未来里，幻想着有一天我会变瘦。
So before you declared to others, OK, I'm fat, how did you see yourself? Did you see yourself as fat? Did you conceive of yourself as fat?
那么在向别人宣布之前，好吧，我就是胖，你是怎么看待自己的？你把自己看作是胖子吗？你有意识到自己是胖子吗？
Yeah, but I was determined to not be fat forever. And my worst fear was, what if I am? And then at some point, I just was like, you know, it's fairly likely that I'm going to be fat forever. So why am I putting off figuring out how to live with that? I should, rather than spending all my time counting almonds, why not try to figure out how to be happy now?
是的，但我下定决心永远不再变胖。我最担心的是，如果我一直这样怎么办？后来，我觉得，你知道，我大概会永远胖下去。所以我为什么要推迟学习如何与此共存呢？比起把所有时间都花在数杏仁上，为什么不试着现在就学会如何快乐呢？
Which means saying to everybody, let's just decide together that, like most fat people, I'll probably always be this way. This is who I am, which-- right now, anyway-- is so rare, it feels like a radical act.
这意味着要对每个人说，我们一起决定吧，像大多数胖子一样，我可能永远都会是这个样子。这就是我，无论如何，目前这太罕见了，感觉就像一种激进的行为。
I'm fat.
我很胖。
It's so weird to actually hear you say I'm fat. I actually heard you say that. I don't think I've ever actually heard somebody just say those words except in a much smaller context, like somebody puts on a dress and it's like, oh, I'm fat. But they don't mean, this is who I am.
听到你说“我很胖”真的太奇怪了。我真的听你说了出来。我不认为我曾经听过谁真正说出这些话，除非是在一个小得多的语境下，比如有人穿上一件裙子，然后说，哦，我好胖。但他们不是指“这就是我”。
Yeah, and it's usually thin people who say that.
是的，而且通常是瘦子才会那样说。
Yeah.
是的。
You know?
你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
When you come out as gay, most people accept it, because they know you can't do anything about that. That's who you are. You can't change it. But coming out as fat, doctors and your family and kind of the entire culture is organized to point out how wrong-headed you are.
当你以同性恋身份出柜时，大多数人会接受，因为他们知道你对此无能为力。这就是你。你无法改变它。但当你以胖子的身份出柜时，医生、你的家人以及整个文化都被组织起来，指出你的思想是多么错误。
When you're over a certain size-- it's been explained to me by a few people now-- complete strangers walk up to you on the street and tell you to lose weight. They shoot you dirty looks when they see ice cream in your shopping cart. They talk down to you like you're stupid about nutrition and calories, as if pretty much every fat person has not been around the block 500 times on that one already.
当你超过一定尺寸时——几个人已经向我解释过了——完全陌生的人会走在大街上告诉你减肥。当他们在你的购物推车里看到冰淇淋时，他们会给你使眼色。他们用一种你对营养和卡路里一无所知的态度跟你说话，就好像几乎每个胖子还没在那个问题上绕过500次弯一样。
That's why deciding to stay fat and be OK with it is at a peculiar frontier right now, where things are shifting and people do not agree about what is acceptable to say and think. I was talking to Lindy. I used the word "overweight" a few times.
这就是为什么决定保持肥胖并坦然接受它现在处于一个奇特的边缘地带，情况正在发生变化，人们对于什么是可以说和想的意见并不统一。我和琳迪交谈时，用了几次“超重”这个词。
And at some point, she stopped me and said, the word "overweight" is not preferred. She wasn't strident about this. It was super friendly. She said the problem with "overweight" is that it implies that there is a correct weight for people.
有一次，她打断我说，不建议使用“超重”这个词。她在这方面并不严厉。非常友好。她说“超重”的问题在于它暗示了人们有一个正确的体重。
That's how radical this is. It's saying that no weight is better than any other weight, which, given the health risks associated with greater weight that Lindy acknowledges, it can be hard to get your head around. And we're doing this show today because I read the book that Lindy just published about this. And it made me see this whole thing differently.
这就是它的激进之处。它表示没有任何体重比其他体重更好，鉴于琳迪也承认更大体重带来的健康风险，这让人很难接受。我们今天做这期节目是因为我读了琳迪刚出版的关于此事的书。它让我以不同的方式看待整个事情。
And so what we're going to do today is we're going to present some excerpts from her book. Her book's called Shrill. And we're going to hear from people who definitely do not feel the same way that Lindy does about all this. For WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以我们今天要做的是，我们要展示她书中的一些节选。她的书叫《尖锐》。我们将听到那些绝对不同意琳迪观点的人的看法。这里是WBEZ芝加哥的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, The Day the Scales Fell from Her Eyes. So Lindy West is very much a fat person with a before picture and an after picture. In both pictures, she's fat. In the after picture, she is outspoken and happy. In the before picture, she is painfully shy and not as happy.
第一幕，天平从她眼中落下的那一天。琳迪·韦斯特是一个有着“之前”照片和“之后”照片的十足的胖子。在两张照片中，她都很胖。在“之后”的照片中，她直言不讳且很快乐。在“之前”的照片中，她非常害羞，也不那么快乐。
She says, as a fat teenager, she felt like a monster. Cool clothes did not seem to exist for her. In her 20s, fat made her world smaller. She'd stay home when friends went hiking, biking, sailing. She'd cancel plans to avoid restaurants whose tables were so close together she couldn't navigate through them.
她说，作为一个胖胖的青少年，她觉得自己像个怪物。凉爽的衣服似乎并不适合她。在20多岁时，肥胖让她的世界变小了。当朋友们去远足、骑自行车、划船时，她会待在家里。她会取消计划以避开那些桌子摆得太挤以至于她无法从中通过的餐馆。
And then not to mention the fact that you're knocking stuff over. You know, just moving through the world as a big person is hard. I take up a lot of space. It's undeniable. It's awkward and embarrassing. And I'm just constantly knocking stuff over with my butt, you know?
而且更不用说你还会撞到东西。你知道，作为一个大个子在世界上走动是很困难的。我占据了很大的空间。这是不可否认的。这很尴尬也很丢脸。我总是用屁股撞到东西，你知道吗？
She describes being fat as simultaneously being way too visible and being invisible-- not wanting people looking at her, noticing her, noticing what she eats. She worried-- and she worries still, all the time-- about destroying chairs by sitting on them.
她描述肥胖的感觉是，既太引人注目又隐形——不想让人盯着她看，注意到她，注意到她吃什么。她担心——而且现在仍然一直担心——坐坏椅子。
[SIGH] Chairs.
[叹气] 椅子。
You catch that? Until this interview, it never occurred to me that a human being could sigh that way over chairs.
你注意到了吗？直到这次采访，我从未想过一个人会对椅子发出那样的叹息。
[SIGH] Chairs.
[叹气] 椅子。
For the record, she says she's only destroyed one chair. It was at a friend's comedy show.
顺便说一句，她说她只坐坏过一把椅子。那是在她朋友的喜剧表演上。
You know, packed, sold-out theater. And I'm sitting on the stage. And then, of course, the chair made a horrible, loud cracking noise, like, five minutes into the show. And I was already on high alert for the chair. So I managed to sort of leap into a crouch.
你知道，满座的剧院。我坐在舞台上。然后，当然，演出开始五分钟后，椅子发出了可怕、响亮的碎裂声。我当时对椅子已经高度警惕了。所以我设法跳进了一个蹲姿。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
As if trained for it.
好像受过训练一样。
Exactly. It was like Mission Impossible . Because breaking a chair is a combination of so many horrible things. It's like confirmation that you are giant, that furniture cannot withstand you. So it's like falling down, making a scene--
正是。就像《碟中谍》一样。因为坐坏椅子是许多可怕事情的结合。这就像是你很巨大，家具承受不住你的证明。所以这就像跌倒、制造骚乱——
You're on stage, so people can see you.
你在舞台上，所以人们能看到你。
Yeah, I'm sure people in the audience-- I mean, well, a guy came running out with a chair.
是的，我肯定观众席里的人——我的意思是，嗯，有个家伙跑出来搬了一把椅子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Of course.
当然。
Then how do you go about the, like, OK, nothing to look at here, nothing--
然后你怎么去处理，像，“好吧，没什么好看的，没什么——”
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
How do you do that?
你怎么做到的？
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
Nothing's going on here.
这里什么都没发生。
I think I just started nodding a lot to the comedy, like, ooh, yeah. But those things just make you stronger, Ira.
我想我只是开始对喜剧点头，好像，噢，是的。但艾拉，那些事情只会让你更坚强。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
In fact, the question she's asked most often these days is, where do you get your confidence? Which is kind of a messed up question, because the subtext is, if I looked like you, I'd definitely throw myself into the sea. Fact is, though, it is a good question.
事实上，如今她被问到最多的问题是：你从哪里得到的自信？这是一个很糟糕的问题，因为潜台词是，如果我长得像你，我绝对会投海自尽。不过事实是，这确实是一个好问题。
How she went from somebody who never wanted to be noticed as fat or at all, to somebody who tells her well-meaning friends that, yes, she wants them to call her fat, even though it makes them feel a little uncomfortable at first. She says it took years, involved many humiliations, things she realized.
她是如何从一个从不想被人注意到胖，或者根本不想被注意的人，变成一个告诉她善意的朋友说，是的，她希望他们叫她胖子的人，尽管这起初让他们感到有点不舒服。她说这花了好几年时间，经历了许多屈辱，以及她意识到的事情。
But the biggest turning point-- the moment that she actually came out and said to everyone she knows that she's fat-- happened as the result of a fight she got into with her boss-- or, to be more precise, the boss of her boss. She was working at a weekly newspaper, The Stranger , in Seattle. She got into a fight with the paper's editorial director.
但最大的转折点——她真正出柜并告诉所有她认识的人她很胖的那一刻——是她与老板——或者更准确地说，她老板的老板——发生争执的结果。她在西雅图的一家周刊报纸《陌生人》工作。她与报纸的编辑总监发生了争执。
His name is Dan Savage. And if you listen to our show a lot, you know him. He's been on many, many times. I've also appeared on his podcast and Vice program, which I recommend wholeheartedly, the Savage Lovecast . He's also written books. He appears on TV.
他的名字叫丹·萨维奇。如果你经常听我们的节目，你就会认识他。他来过很多很多次。我也出现在他的播客和Vice节目中，我衷心推荐《萨维奇之爱》。他也写过书。他出现在电视上。
Dan is friends with Lindy today and had no interest at all in coming on to the radio to revisit this fight that they had a couple years ago. Lindy writes about what happened between them in her book. I asked her to read this part of her story for us here. That's going to be the rest of this act. She says, "Dan was a great boss. But starting around 2004, 2005, he began writing sometimes about obesity." OK, here's Lindy reading.
丹今天和琳迪是朋友，根本没兴趣来广播节目里回顾他们几年前的争执。琳迪在她的书中写了他们之间发生的事情。我让她为我们朗读她故事的这一部分。这将是本幕的其余内容。她说：“丹是个好老板。但从2004、2005年开始，他开始偶尔写关于肥胖的文章。”好的，这是琳迪的朗读。
My boss, Dan, was on something of an obesity epidemic kick. He wasn't alone. The rest of the nation had declared a war on obesity. They'd whipped up a host of reasons why it was right and good to hate fat people-- our repulsive, unsexy bodies, of course, the classic, but also our drain on the health care system, our hogging of plane armrests, our impact on "the children," our pathetic inability and/or monstrous refusal to swap austerity for gluttony, oh, and our health, because they care.
我的老板丹迷上了“肥胖流行病”。他不孤单。全国都已经向肥胖宣战了。他们炮制了一系列理由，为什么仇恨胖子是正确且良好的——当然，是我们令人作呕、毫无性吸引力的身体，不仅如此，还有我们对医疗体系的消耗、对飞机扶手的霸占、对“孩子们”的影响，我们可悲地无能和/或厚颜无耻地拒绝用节制交换暴饮暴食，哦，还有我们的健康，因为他们关心。
Dan was on that train, and I don't blame him. It was a very popular and, I imagine, gratifying ticket at the time. And even more so than today, it was considered very roguish to tell it like it is about fat people. Dan's main sticking point seemed to be fat people like me who insisted we weren't imminently dying.
丹就在那列火车上，我不怪他。那在当时是一张非常流行且我想很有成就感的门票。比今天更甚，告诉人们关于胖子的真相被认为是非常时髦的。丹的主要痛点似乎是像我这样坚持认为我们没有即将死去的胖子。
He fiercely and persistently defended his, quote, "refusal to take the self-esteem-boosting/public-health-shredding position that you can be obese and healthy. More than anything, this passage from his 2005 book, The Commitment , sums up the overall tone of his stance at the time on fatties. Here's the quote.
他激烈而坚持地捍卫他所谓的“拒绝接受那种提振自尊/破坏公共卫生——即你可以肥胖又健康——的立场”。最重要的是，他2005年的书《承诺》中的这段话总结了他当时对胖子的总体立场。这是引言。
"Two days later, in a water park in Sioux Falls, South Dakota, I came to a couple of realizations. First, anyone who denies the existence of the obesity epidemic in the United States hasn't been to a water park in Sioux Falls, South Dakota.
“两天后，在南达科他州苏福尔斯的游乐园里，我有了几点认识。首先，任何否认美国存在肥胖流行病的人肯定没去过苏福尔斯的游乐园。”
The owners of water parks in the US must be saving a fortune on water and chlorine bills. Floating in the deep end of the wave pool with DJ, Terry observed that there was an awful lot of water being displaced. If the South Dakotans floating around us all got out of the pool at the same time, the water level would most likely have dropped 6 feet."
“美国的游乐园老板一定在水费和氯气费上省了一大笔钱。在造浪池的深处漂浮时，泰瑞观察到这里排开了大量的水。如果漂浮在我们周围的南达科他州人同时离开池子，水位很可能会下降6英尺。”
That's what Dan wrote. In other words, we're horrible to look at. We're in the way. We're a joke.
这就是丹写的。换句话说，我们看起来很可怕。我们挡道了。我们是个笑话。
I could probably have dealt with that. But I started to get comments here and there from readers asking how it felt to know that my boss hated me because of my body. I knew Dan didn't hate me. But why didn't he see that when he wrote about fat people he was writing about me, Lindy West, his colleague and friend? And why should I, as an employee, have to swallow that kind of treatment at my job, in the same newspaper I was sweating blood into for 36K a year? Did I want to be the kind of person who didn't fight?
我可能本来能处理好这件事。但我开始时不时收到读者的评论，问我知道我的老板因为我的身体而讨厌我时是什么感觉。我知道丹并不讨厌我。但他为什么不明白，当他写关于胖子的文章时，他是在写我，琳迪·韦斯特，他的同事和朋友？而且作为一个雇员，为什么我必须在工作中吞下那种对待，在同一份我以年薪3.6万为之流血流汗的报纸里？我想成为那种不反抗的人吗？
OK, so I'm going to jump in here. Lindy decided to take a stand. And she did as a culmination of a bunch of experiences and changes in the way that she thought about being fat. And I talked to her about this in our interview.
好了，我要插一句。琳迪决定采取立场。这是她一系列经历和对肥胖想法转变的顶峰。我在采访中和她谈过这件事。
One of the big things was, she saw these photos taken by the actor Leonard Nimoy, the guy who played Mr. Spock on Star Trek . Late in his life, he did a series of these gorgeous black-and-white photos called The Full Body Project , where he photographed fat women naked.
其中一件大事是，她看到了演员伦纳德·尼莫伊拍摄的照片，就是《星际迷航》里饰演斯波克的那个人。在他生命的晚年，他拍摄了一系列名为《全身计划》的华丽黑白照片，他拍摄了裸体的胖女人。
And they're presented as objects of beauty. They're art photos. And I just had never seen that before ever in my life. It had never occurred to me that you would do anything with a fat body other than hide it. And the women in these photographs were so proud and just full of life. And it really had an impact on me. I mean, at first, I was really uncomfortable.
它们被呈现为美的客体。它们是艺术摄影。我一生中从未见过这样的照片。我从未想过除了隐藏胖身体之外，还能用它做别的什么事。照片里的女性是那么自豪，充满了生命力。这真的对我产生了影响。我的意思是，起初我非常不舒服。
Uncomfortable, like, oh, no, don't show that.
不舒服，就像，哦，不，别展示那个。
Yeah, like, you guys!
是的，就像，你们这些家伙！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That's secret!
那是秘密！
You guys, I've been working really hard on not showing this to people.
你们这些家伙，我一直在努力不向人们展示这一点。
From there, she started searching the internet with the intensity, she says, of a teenager looking for porn, only she was looking for sites where they posted images of fat people. There's a bunch of Tumblrs along these lines. Some are basically just fashion blogs for fat people. Finding decent clothes is an issue if you're really big. There's a Tumblr called, "hey, fat chick!"
从那里，她开始以一个青少年寻找色情片那样的强度在互联网上搜索，只不过她是在寻找发布胖子图像的网站。有很多这样的Tumblr博客。有些基本就是胖子的时尚博客。如果你很胖，寻找得体的衣服是一个问题。有一个Tumblr叫“嘿，胖妞！”
I mean, this was just my favorite one of these fat acceptance blogs. It was just that. It was just bright, happy, funny, smiling people wearing cute outfits. It's just, you're so used to seeing fat people presented as sad and apologetic.
我的意思是，这是我最喜欢的这些胖子接受博客之一。它就是那样。它只是明亮、快乐、有趣、面带微笑、穿着可爱衣服的人。你只是太习惯于看到胖子被表现得悲伤和道歉了。
And what did this do to you? What it do to see that?
这为你做了什么？看到这些有什么感觉？
I remember feeling like my brain was changing shape. It just had never occurred to me that you could just decide that you were allowed to be happy and live as a--
我记得感觉我的大脑在改变形状。从来没想过你可以决定你被允许快乐并作为一个——
As a fat person.
作为一个胖子生活。
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And did this change the way that you saw fat people?
这改变了你对胖子的看法吗？
Yeah, I mean, I can't even explain how strange it was, because it was like-- it wasn't just conceptual, like, oh, I deserve to be happy. It was like I was looking at specific parts of their bodies and staring at them-- parts of their bodies that I had always just reviled on myself.
是的，我的意思是，我甚至无法解释它有多么奇怪，因为它不仅仅是概念上的，比如，哦，我应该快乐。它就像我盯着他们身体的特定部位——那些我在自己身上一直厌恶的部位。
Like, what do you mean?
比如，你是什么意思？
You know, like fat rolls and arm fat and bellies and staring at them and saying, OK, what if I found that objectively beautiful? What if I decided that's beautiful?
你知道，就像脂肪褶、胳膊上的肉和肚子，盯着它们看，然后说，好吧，如果我客观地觉得这很美呢？如果我决定那很美呢？
And then does that work?
然后这管用吗？
Yes, it does. At least, it worked for me.
是的，管用。至少，对我管用。
And then it really looked beautiful.
然后它真的看起来很美。
Yeah, really. Really, genuinely. And it felt like some sort of sorcery. Like, at the time, I was like, how is this possible?
是的，真的。真的，真心实意地。感觉就像某种巫术。就像，当时我心想，这怎么可能？
Lindy says in her book, "Want to change the way you see fat people? Try it." So that stuff is rewiring her brain, and she's thinking about it a lot. And to get back to our story, her boss is saying these demeaning things about fat people. And she decides, enough. OK, back to her reading. And I'll just say we have unbeeped some words here on the internet version of our show. If you preferred a beeped version, there's one on our website.
琳迪在书中说：“想改变你对胖子的看法吗？试试看。”所以那些东西在重塑她的大脑，她想了很多。回到我们的故事，她的老板在说那些贬低胖子的话。她决定，受够了。好的，回到她的朗读。我要说的是，我们在节目网络版中没有消掉一些词。如果你更喜欢消音版，我们的网站上有一个。
Something lurched awake inside of me. A lifetime of being talked down to about nutrition, being kept secret by men I was dating, being both invisible and too visible finally foamed up and spilled over. I emailed Dan privately in November of 2009.
某种东西在我内心觉醒了。一辈子被说教营养问题、被我约会的男人当成秘密、既隐形又太引人注目，终于像泡沫一样翻涌出来。2009年11月，我私下给丹发了一封邮件。
In my memory, I asked him to please, please consider his words more carefully before writing about fat people, to remember that we're human beings with complex lives, not disease vectors or animals. I was timid, pleading. Or at least, that's how I remember it.
在我的记忆中，我请他务必在写关于胖子的文章前更慎重地斟酌他的用词，记住我们是有复杂生活的血肉之躯，而不是疾病携带者或动物。我当时很胆怯、恳求。或者至少，我是这么记得的。
While writing about all this, I looked up the original exchange. And it turns out that my memory sucks. Here's the actual email that I sent to my actual boss. "To Dan Savage. Subject-- hello, could you lay off the fat people shit?
在写这些的时候，我查了原始的交流。结果我的记忆太烂了。这是我发给真正老板的实际邮件。“致丹·萨维奇。主题——嘿，能别再扯胖子的狗屁事了吗？”
Just curious. Who are these hordes of fat people chasing you around, insisting that eating pot pies all day is awesome and good for your health? Because, um, I don't believe you. That sounds like a strawman. And I know some of your best friends are fat or whatever, but you sound like a bigot. Also, your super fucking obvious and regressive point has been made. Everyone in the world already thinks fat people are lazy and gross."
“纯属好奇。到底是哪群胖子在你身后追着你，坚持说整天吃馅饼很棒且对健康有益？因为，嗯，我不相信你。那听起来像个稻草人谬论。我知道你最好的朋友里也有胖子什么的，但你听起来像个偏执狂。而且，你那些超级明显的退步观点已经被说过了。世界上每个人都已经认为胖子很懒且恶心了。”
Then I went all caps. "WE GET IT! YOU ARE NOT BREAKING NEW GROUND HERE!" Back to regular case. "Being fat is its own punishment. I don't give a shit if you think I lie on the couch all day under the Dorito funnel. I'd just rather not be abused on the internet from inside my own workplace. Just a thought. Love, Lindy."
然后我全用大写字母写道。“我们懂了！你并没有在开辟新领域！”回到正常大小写。“胖本身就是一种惩罚。我才不管你是否认为我整天躺在沙发上吃薯片。我只是不想在自己的工作场所遭到网暴。只是个想法。爱你的，琳迪。”
Dan's reply was nine words long. He asked simply if I'd ever detected any animus from him personally. "Nope, not at all," I wrote. "Not my point at all either." He said he heard me, but I was accusing him of being a bigot-- a serious charge against someone exhibiting, by my admission, no animus. It was a dodge. He was deliberately missing the point. We never talked about it in the office.
丹的回复只有九个字。他简单地问我是否曾感觉到他个人的敌意。“不，完全没有，”我写道。“那也不是我的重点。”他说他听到了，但我指责他是个偏执狂——这对一个在我承认的情况下没有表现出任何敌意的人来说是一个严重的指控。这是一种回避。他在故意歪曲重点。我们在办公室里从没谈过这件事。
For the next year, he went back to posting semi-regularly about the horrors of the obesity epidemic with no discernible interruption. And I went back to ignoring him. Then Dan wrote a blog post entitled "Ban Fat Marriage." He was responding to some Republicans' argument that gay marriage should be illegal because gay people supposedly die younger.
接下来的一年，他又回到了半定期发布关于肥胖流行病恐怖的文章，没有任何明显的停顿。而我也回到了无视他的状态。然后丹写了一篇博文，标题为“禁止胖人结婚”。他在回应一些共和党人的论点，即同性婚姻应该非法，因为同性恋者往往死得更早。
Here's Dan. Quote, "Why stop with gay people? Iowa should ban fat marriage. There are, according to the state of Iowa, more than 1.4 million obese people living in Iowa. The social costs of Iowa's obesity epidemic are pretty staggering. And those costs include premature death and lower average life expectancies for Iowans."
这是丹的话。引用，“为什么要止步于同性恋者？爱荷华州应该禁止胖人结婚。据爱荷华州统计，有超过140万肥胖者住在爱荷华州。爱荷华州肥胖流行病的社会成本相当惊人。这些成本包括过早死亡和爱荷华州人较低的平均预期寿命。”
In response, I threw up a quick blog post. "Hey, Dan. So now that you're equating the stigmatization of fat people with the stigmatization of gay people, does that mean you're going to stop stigmatizing fat people on this blog?" Nothing. I waited a few days. Nothing.
作为回应，我快速发布了一篇博客。“嘿，丹。既然你现在把对胖子的污名化与对同性恋者的污名化等同起来，那是不是意味着你打算停止在这个博客上污名化胖子了？”什么都没有。我等了几天。什么都没有。
I looked back over our old email exchange. My private confrontation with Dan had gotten me nowhere. Taking a quick, vague swipe at him on the blog had gotten me nowhere. So I did what honestly I thought Dan Savage would do, what he'd taught me to do over my years at the paper.
我回看了我们旧的邮件交流。我和丹的私下对抗没能让我取得任何进展。在博客上对他进行模糊的攻击也没能让我取得任何进展。所以我做了我真心认为丹·萨维奇会做的事，他在报社这些年来教我做的事。
On February 11, 2011, I wrote a scorched-earth essay and posted it publicly at the tail end of a sunny Friday afternoon. The post was called, "Hello, I Am Fat." It included a full body photo of me taken that day by Kelly O, our staff photographer, with the caption, "28 years old, female, 5 foot 9, 263 pounds."
2011年2月11日，我写了一篇焦土政策式的文章，并在那个阳光明媚的周五下午尾声公之于众。那篇文章标题叫“你好，我很胖”。它包含了当天由我们的员工摄影师凯莉·O拍摄的一张我的全身照，标题是：“28岁，女性，5英尺9英寸，263磅。”
It read as follows. "This is my body, over there. See it? I have lived in this body my whole life. I have wanted to change this body my whole life.
内容如下。“这就是我的身体，在那边。看到了吗？我一生都住在这个身体里。我一生都想改变这个身体。”
I get that you think you're actually helping people by contributing to the alp of shame that crushes every fat person every day of their lives. But you're not helping. Shame doesn't work. Diets don't work.
“我明白你认为你在通过向每天都在压垮每个胖子的耻辱堆里添砖加瓦来帮助人们。但你没有帮助。羞耻感没用。节食没用。”
Fat people already are ashamed. It's taken care of. No further manpower needed on the shame front. Thanks."
“胖子已经感到羞耻了。这就够了。羞耻这一块不需要更多人力了。谢谢。”
Then I tore into something Dan wrote about fat rolls. Here's the quote. "I am thoroughly annoyed at having my tame statements of fact-- being heavy is a health risk, rolls of exposed flesh are unsightly-- characterized as hate speech."
然后我撕开了丹写的一些关于脂肪褶的东西。这是引言。“我对我的平淡事实陈述——体重超标是健康风险，暴露的脂肪褶很难看——被定性为仇恨言论感到非常恼火。”
Ha! Rolls of exposed flesh are unsightly. That is in no way a tame statement of fact. It's not a fact at all. It's a cruel, subjective opinion.
哈！暴露的脂肪褶很难看。这绝不是平淡的事实陈述。它根本不是事实。这是一种残酷的主观意见。
But this is what's behind this entire thing. It's not about health. It's about "ew." You think fat people are icky. Ew. A fat person might touch you on a plane with their fat. Ew!
但这就是这整件事背后的原因。这与健康无关。这与“恶心”有关。你认为胖子很恶心。恶心。一个胖子在飞机上可能会用他们的脂肪碰到你。恶心！
Coincidentally, that's the same feeling that drives anti-gay bigots. No matter what excuses they drum up about family values and, yes, health, it's all "ew." And sorry, I reject your "ew." You're not concerned about my health. Because if you were concerned about my health, you would also be concerned about my mental health, which has spent the past 28 years being slowly eroded by statements like the above.
巧合的是，这与驱动反同性恋偏执狂的情绪是一样的。无论他们编造出什么关于家庭价值观的借口，是的，健康，一切都是“恶心”。抱歉，我拒绝你的“恶心”。你并不关心我的健康。因为如果你关心我的健康，你也会关心我的心理健康，它在过去28年里被像上述那样的陈述缓慢侵蚀着。
Also, you don't know anything about my health. You do happen to be the boss of me, but you are not the doctor of me. You have no idea what I eat, how much I exercise, what my blood pressure is, or whether or not I'm going to get diabetes. Not that any of that matters, because it is entirely none of your business."
而且，你对我一无所知。你确实碰巧是我的老板，但你不是我的医生。你根本不知道我吃什么、运动多少、血压如何，或者我是否会得糖尿病。并不是说这些有什么关系，因为这完全不关你的事。”
OK, I'm going to jump in one more time here, because this health question is actually kind of the third rail when people talk about fat people. Fat people are told all the time they're choosing to be unhealthy. Lindy and other fat people point out that actually, the causes of obesity are way more complex than just eating too much.
好的，我要再说一句，因为当人们谈论胖子时，这个问题实际上是某种禁忌。胖子总被告知他们选择不健康。琳迪和其他胖子指出，实际上，肥胖的原因比吃太多要复杂得多。
According to the National Institutes of Health, they include physiological, metabolic, genetic, psychological, social, and cultural factors. Also, we haven't invented a way to make fat people thin long term. Fewer than 1 in 100 obese people get thin and keep it off, according to one recent study, which tracked over a quarter million people for nine years.
根据国立卫生研究院的数据，它们包括生理、代谢、遗传、心理、社会和文化因素。此外，我们还没发明出让胖子长期变瘦的方法。根据最近一项跟踪了超过25万人、为期九年的研究，不到1%的肥胖者能变瘦并保持下来。
So we're in this situation, where a third of all Americans are classified as overweight, another third of us are obese. Can it really be that so many of us are just weak and choosing to be unhealthy? There must be some other way to think about this. OK, back to Lindy.
所以我们处于这种情况，三分之一的美国人被归类为超重，另外三分之一是肥胖。真的可能有这么多人只是软弱且选择不健康吗？一定有其他看待这件事的方式。好的，回到琳迪。
I reject this entire framework. I'm not concerned with whether or not fat people can change their bodies through self-discipline and choices. Pretty much all of them have tried already. A couple of them have succeeded. Whatever.
我拒绝接受整个框架。我不关心胖子是否可以通过自律和选择改变他们的身体。他们几乎都试过了。其中几个成功了。管他呢。
My question is, what if they try and try and try and still fail? What if they're still fat? What if they're fat forever? What do you do with them then?
我的问题是，如果他们尝试再尝试，仍然失败了怎么办？如果他们永远都是胖子怎么办？那时候你该拿他们怎么办？
Do you really want millions of teenage girls to feel like they're trapped in bodies that are ruining their lives? And on top of that, it's because of their own moral failure? And on top of that, they're ruining America with the terribly expensive diabetes that they don't even have yet? You know what's shameful? A complete lack of empathy.
你真的希望数百万少女觉得她们被困在正在毁掉她们生活的身体里吗？而且最重要的是，这是因为她们自己的道德失败？而且最重要的是，她们正在用还没得上的昂贵糖尿病毁掉美国？你知道什么才令人羞耻吗？彻底缺乏同理心。
A few days later, Dan Savage wrote a response, by the way, three times longer than Lindy's post. She didn't convince him at all. Dan and she went out once for beer and soft pretzels and talked it out a little to make sure they were still friends. Of course, they still didn't agree.
顺便说一句，几天后，丹·萨维奇写了一篇回应，长度是琳迪的三倍。她根本没说服他。丹和她出去喝了一次啤酒和软椒盐卷饼，稍微谈了谈，以确保他们还是朋友。当然，他们仍然不同意对方。
And then they never spoke about it again. Lindy says in the years since, though, she's noticed-- and Dan says this is true-- he writes about fat people differently. No cheap punchlines. Live and learn, he texted me. Of course, how Lindy writes about fat people was changed by this as well.
然后他们再也没提起过。不过琳迪说这些年来，她注意到了——丹也承认这是真的——他写关于胖子的文章方式变了。没有廉价的笑话。他给我发短信说，“在生活中学习”。当然，琳迪写关于胖子的方式也因此改变了。
"Almost every day, I hear some kind friend say, Sophie, dear, I think you're much too stout. Right away, they suggest the diet they think best. They make me sick. I wish they'd cut it out. I don't want to get thin. I don't want to get thin. Why should I when I'm all right as I am?"
“几乎每天，我都会听到一些好心的朋友说，索菲，亲爱的，我觉得你太壮了。他们立刻建议他们认为最好的节食方法。他们让我恶心。我真希望他们住嘴。我不想变瘦。我不想变瘦。既然我就这样挺好的，我为什么要变瘦呢？”
Act Two, It's a Small World After All. So when we were all talking about what wanted to put on this week's show, we come to the subject of fat suits. And one of our staffers, Elna Baker, blurted out, if she put one of those on today, she'd feel like herself again.
第二幕，世界真小。所以当我们都在讨论本周节目想要放什么内容时，谈到了胖子服装的话题。我们的一位工作人员埃尔娜·贝克脱口而出，如果她今天穿上那样的衣服，她会感觉自己又变回了自己。
Elna is one of those rare people who has lost a lot of weight. She lost 110 pounds, and she's kept it off for years and years. Says she grew up being told the same thing that lots of fat girls are told-- that she'd never have a husband or a family if she stayed fat.
埃尔娜是那种减掉了很多体重的稀有品种。她减掉了110磅，并且多年来一直保持着体重。她说她从小就被告知很多胖女孩被告知的话——如果她一直胖下去，她永远不会有丈夫或家庭。
She'd never got the job she wanted if she stayed fat. The job she wanted in her case was she wanted to be an actress. Her grandfather would tell her flat out, nobody wants to see a fat girl on TV.
如果她一直胖下去，她永远得不到她想要的工作。在她的案例中，她想要的工作是做一名演员。她的祖父会直白地告诉她，没人想在电视上看到一个胖女孩。
But she didn't believe it. She thought it was an exaggeration. She's a hard worker, good attitude. She just figured she'd just make it work. Then it didn't work. Here's Elna.
但她不相信。她以为那是在夸大其词。她工作努力，态度端正。她只觉得她会搞定的。后来没搞定。这是埃尔娜。
A year out of college, I took stock of my life. It was not going as planned. I was unemployed, and I had never been in a relationship. I tried for the life I wanted, hard. I got a scholarship to NYU. I was a huge flirt with lots of guy friends. But it felt like there was an invisible force blocking me from achieving my dreams.
大学毕业一年后，我盘点了我的生活。它没按计划进行。我失业了，也从未谈过恋爱。我努力追求我想要的生活。我获得了纽约大学的奖学金。我是一个非常善于调情的人，有很多男性朋友。但感觉就像有一种隐形的力量阻止我实现梦想。
Sure, I'd think, is it because I'm fat? But then I'd think, don't be paranoid. I refused to believe that people were that shallow. It had to be more complicated. I tried to put my finger on it, but I just couldn't figure it out. Once I lost weight, I realized, it was all because I was fat.
当然，我会想，是因为我胖吗？但然后我会想，别多疑了。我拒绝相信人们那么肤浅。一定更复杂。我试着指出这一点，但我就是想不明白。减肥后，我意识到，那全是因为我胖。
It felt like that famous Eddie Murphy sketch on Saturday Night Live , where he goes undercover in whiteface and gets treated way better. He rides the city bus. And when the last black rider gets off, music starts. A cocktail waitress in a sequined dress hands out martinis. That's what I felt like-- like this whole other world for thin people had existed alongside mine, a world they've been keeping a secret from me.
感觉就像周六夜现场那个著名的艾迪·墨菲小品，他在那里化了白人妆，受到了更好的对待。他乘坐城市巴士。当最后一个黑人乘客下车时，音乐开始了。一个穿着亮片裙的鸡尾酒女侍者递出马提尼酒。这就是我的感受——就像这个属于瘦人的整个世界一直存在于我的世界旁边，一个他们一直对我保密的秘密世界。
When I was fat and I walked down the street, people would stare. I'd hear comments that I would ignore. Occasionally someone would shout something out at me. In this new world, when I walked down the street, attractive men and women would do something to me they'd never done before. They would look me up and down, and then they would nod their heads. Thin people nod at each other?
当我胖的时候，我走在街上，人们会盯着看。我会听到一些我忽略的评论。偶尔有人会冲我喊些什么。在这个新世界里，当我走在街上时，吸引人的男女会对做一件他们以前从未对我做过的事。他们会上下打量我，然后点头。瘦人会点头致意？
One day, I went to pay for my groceries at a deli and realized I was short, off by a full $10. I looked at my pile and began debating what would stay and what would go. The deli guy waved his hand. "Just take it," he said. Take it? I walked out cautiously, not sure what had just happened.
有一天，我去熟食店结账，意识到钱不够，差了整整10美元。我看着我的那堆东西，开始纠结留下什么，放弃什么。熟食店老板挥了挥手。“拿走吧，”他说。拿走？我小心翼翼地走出去，不确定刚才发生了什么。
So I tried the same thing at a different deli, this time on purpose. I picked out more items than I had money for. Then I faked debating which ones to choose. "Just take it," the man behind the counter said. Soon it was a scam I ran all over the city. It wasn't about saving money. I wanted to know, is this is a thing? It's a thing.
所以我尝试在另一家熟食店如法炮制，这次是故意的。我挑的东西比我有的钱多。然后我假装纠结选哪些。柜台后的男人说：“拿走吧。”很快，这成了我在这座城市里玩的把戏。这与省钱无关。我想知道，这是一种现象吗？这确实是。
Of course, I'd lost the weight to fix two specific problems. I wanted to get a job and find love. Old Elna looked for a job for a year and a half. New Elna was offered work a month after she hit her goal weight, an entry-level position on an actual TV show.
当然，我减肥是为了解决两个具体的问题。我想找份工作，寻找爱情。旧埃尔娜找工作找了一年半。新埃尔娜在她达到目标体重一个月后就被提供了工作，一个实际电视节目上的入门级职位。
I was hired to be a page at the Letterman show. My job was to walk down the line of people waiting to go into the theater and divide them into three groups-- dots, generals, and CBS twos. The dots were the beautiful people. They got seated in the first three rows. Usually those were the only rows you saw on television.
我被聘为莱特曼秀的引座员。我的工作是走在排队等候进入剧院的人群中，把他们分成三组——点点、将军和CBS二组。点点是美女。她们被安排在前三排。通常那是你电视上唯一看到的排数。
Generals were average people. They sat in the order they arrived. CBS two was for fat people, elderly people with a visible illness, people who looked like they might be disruptive, and goths. I'd scribble CBS two on their ticket. And that was code for, seat them in the back three rows at the balcony-- the nosebleed seats. I'd seen Letterman a few years earlier. I was near the front of the line and somehow ended up in the nosebleeds. I remember being confused by it. The day I was trained, I put it together.
将军是普通人。他们按到达顺序就座。CBS二组是为胖子、有明显疾病的老人、看起来可能会有破坏性的人以及哥特人准备的。我会在他们的票上潦草地写上CBS二组。那是代码，意思是让他们坐在阳台的后三排——那是非常远的位置。我几年前看过莱特曼。我当时在队头，结果不知怎么坐到了最远的位置。我记得对此很困惑。我受训的那天，我把它联系起来了。
I lost weight so fast-- close to 100 pounds in 5 and 1/2 months-- that it was like going from one human to another. Here's how I did it. I enrolled in a weight loss clinic. The doctor gave me a list of foods I could eat and told me I had to exercise daily. Your diet will be aided by medicine, he told me-- potassium, serotonin, dopamine, a multi-vitamin, and then phentermine, which would help suppress my appetite.
我瘦得太快了——5个半月内近100磅——感觉就像从一个人变成了另一个人。我是这样做的。我报名参加了一个减肥诊所。医生给了我一张我可以吃的食物清单，告诉我要每天运动。你的饮食会得到药物辅助，他告诉我——钾、血清素、多巴胺、复合维生素，然后是芬特明，它会帮助抑制我的食欲。
I look down at the little colored tablets. Skittles, I thought, only the opposite. I began my diet with a prayer for grace. I was Mormon then. I asked God to give me the same willpower Jesus had when he fasted in the wilderness for 40 days. I prayed for his self-control.
我低头看着那些彩色小药片。彩虹糖，我想，只是反过来的。我带着对恩典的祈祷开始了我的节食。那时候我是摩门教徒。我请求上帝给我耶稣在旷野禁食40天时那样的意志力。我祈求他的自控力。
Then I took the first pill, phentermine, which is similar to amphetamines-- speed. I'd never done drugs before. Remember, I was Mormon. I'd never even tried coffee. I didn't know how a substance could alter your state of being. And so when I became so focused, so driven, so able not to eat, and so into cleaning, I was certain my prayer had been answered. I was sure it was God. I kept a journal during that time and recently read from it on stage.
然后我吃了第一片芬特明，它类似于安非他命——毒品。我以前从没碰过毒品。记住，我是摩门教徒。我甚至从没试过咖啡。我不知道物质怎么能改变你的存在状态。所以当我变得如此专注、如此有干劲、如此能不吃饭，并且如此热爱打扫卫生时，我确信我的祈祷得到了回应。我确信那是上帝。在那段时间里，我写了一本日记，最近在舞台上读了其中的一部分。
This is from my journal. So I'm doing it. I'm taking control over my body. In the last month and 10 days, I have lost 30 pounds. I cannot deny Heavenly Father's role in this whole process.
这是我的日记。“所以我在做了。我正在掌控我的身体。在一个月零10天里，我减掉了30磅。我无法否认天父在整个过程中扮演的角色。”
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
[笑声和掌声]
I am receiving divine help. I basically feel like I am possessed by an alien.
我得到了神圣的帮助。我基本上感觉自己被外星人附身了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Now I just have to keep going. And this is after-- so after I'd lost, like, 60 pounds, it was like the racial breakdown. I would walk down the street. Black dudes noticed me. 10 more pounds, Hispanic guys noticed me. 20 more pounds, white guys noticed me. And Asian guys have never noticed me!
现在我只需要继续前进。这是在——所以在减掉60磅之后，这就像种族细分一样。我走在街上，黑人哥们注意我。再减10磅，西班牙裔男注意我。20磅，白人注意我。而亚裔男从来没注意过我！
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I have never been thin enough for Asian men.
我从来没瘦到能入亚裔男的眼。
I'd only been kissed a handful of times when I was fat. Each ended with the guys saying the same exact thing-- "don't tell anyone about this." I was hoping that losing weight might change all that. And it did. New Elna kissed 16 guys in eight weeks. I know this, because I drew a map in my journal of the city and marked the location of each kiss with an X, geolocating it.
我胖的时候只被亲过几次。每次结束时，男生都说完全一样的话——“别告诉任何人这件事。”我希望减肥能改变这一切。结果确实改变了。新埃尔娜在八周内吻了16个男的。我知道这一点，因为我在日记里画了一张城市地图，并用X标记了每次亲吻的地点，进行了地理定位。
Nine months in, I started seeing a guy from my building-- a kindergarten teacher who left love notes on my door. And we started to really fall for each other. One night, he told me, "I liked you from the first moment I saw you." He was referring to the building barbecue we'd hung out at a few weeks earlier.
九个月后，我开始和一个我大楼里的家伙约会——一个会在我门上留情话的幼儿园老师。我们开始真正坠入爱河。一天晚上，他告诉我，“我第一眼看到你就喜欢你。”他指的是几周前我们参加的大楼烧烤聚会。
But we'd met long before that barbecue. We'd lived in the same small building for four years. One day, when I was still fat, I'd knocked on his door and asked to borrow a hammer. When I brought it back, we talked for 20 minutes.
但我们在那个烧烤聚会之前很久就见过面。我们在同一栋小楼里住了四年。有一天，我还没瘦下来时，我敲了他的门，借了把锤子。我送还锤子时，我们谈了20分钟。
After that, I knew him. He was Andy in 3C. We nodded when we saw each other in the hallway. Now he had no idea that girl was me.
那之后，我认识了他。他是3C室的安迪。在走廊里见到时，我们会点头。现在他根本不知道那个女孩就是我。
We dated for another two months, but I couldn't let it go. It just spoiled everything. I thought we were falling in love. I thought it was real. But it was based on the way I looked. He couldn't even see me when I was fat. I didn't matter until I was this size.
我们又约会了两个月，但我无法放手。它毁了一切。我以为我们坠入爱河了。我以为那是真的。但它是建立在我外表的基础上的。他胖的时候甚至看不到我。直到我变成这个尺寸，我才变得重要。
The attention I got from men, I wrote in my journal, I wish I could just enjoy it. Instead it made me sad. It was the unfairness that got to me. Old Elna longed for someone like Andy and never got him. She tried so hard for everything that I now got so easily.
我从男人那里得到的关注，我在日记里写道，我希望我能享受它。相反，它让我悲伤。是不公平让我难受。旧埃尔娜渴望像安迪那样的人，却从没得到。她为了得到我现在如此轻易得到的一切而苦苦挣扎。
New Elna didn't have to be a good person. I just had to be thin. It made the world seem so bleak, like this is the system? Really? It made me less hopeful about people. When guys came on to me, it didn't feel like it was about me. I could be anyone. It made it hard to trust people.
新埃尔娜不需要成为一个好人。我只需要瘦。这让世界看起来如此荒凉，就像这套系统？真的吗？这让我对人们不那么抱有希望。当男人们对我献殷勤时，感觉那不是为了我。我可以是任何人。这让人很难信任别人。
Can I just say another word about this? It's just such an unbalanced reward system. It took so much more kindness, hard work, and ingenuity to be a person in the world when I was fat. All this took was not eating.
我能再说一句吗？这是一个极其不平衡的奖励机制。当我胖的时候，作为一个人在世界上生活，需要更多的善良、努力工作和智慧。而现在所需要的仅仅是不吃饭。
Here's something that surprised me. It wasn't enough to take diet pills. It wasn't enough to lose the weight of an entire adult woman from my own body. Once I did all that, I realized I still wasn't actually thin. Not really. After dropping the weight, I had so much extra skin that I could lay on my side and pull it a half foot in either direction.
这里有一件事让我感到惊讶。服用减肥药是不够的。减掉一个成年女人的体重是不够的。做完这一切后，我意识到我其实还没变瘦。不是真正的。减肥后，我有多余的皮肤，我可以躺在侧面，把它们向两边拉半英尺。
For a long time, I tried to get the skin to go away with lotions and exercise. Eventually, I resorted to surgery-- in fact, four different surgeries. They included something called a circumferential body lift. They made an incision around my entire waist, cut out a 6-inch belt of skin, and then sewed me back together.
很长一段时间，我试着用乳液和运动让皮肤消失。最后，我诉诸手术——事实上，做了四次不同的手术。其中包括一种叫做环形身体提升的手术。他们绕着我的整个腰部切了一个切口，切掉了一圈6英寸的皮肤，然后把我缝合起来。
I also got a thigh lift. They cut up my legs from my knees to my groin and took out as much skin as they could. Now I have a scar that runs completely around my waist, as if a magician cut me in half. I also have two scars running up my legs like inseams.
我还做了大腿提升术。他们从我的膝盖切到腹股沟，尽可能多地切除了皮肤。现在我腰部周围有一道疤痕，就像魔术师把我切成两半一样。我的腿上也留下了两道像内缝线一样的疤痕。
In order for my legs to heal, I had to sit alone in a room for a month without any underwear and my legs spread eagle. It's OK. I made it through every season of The Wire . But it was a painful month. One night, I went to pee, and the incision along my crotch split open two inches, not unlike splitting the crotch of your jeans, except it was my actual crotch.
为了让腿部愈合，我不得不独自在一个房间里坐了一个月，不穿内衣，双腿张开。没关系。我看完了每一季的《火线》。但这痛苦的一个月。一天晚上，我去小便，腹股沟的切口裂开了两英寸，这和牛仔裤胯部裂开没什么两样，除了那是我的真实胯部。
I called the doctor in a panic. He told me he couldn't sew it back up together without a risk of infection. So I had to pack the wound with gauze and keep packing it. I tried to pack it myself, but I was too hurt to move. As I bent forward, I heard it split even more.
我惊恐地给医生打电话。他告诉我，如果不冒感染的风险，他无法把它缝回去。所以我不得不往伤口里塞纱布，并继续塞。我试着自己塞，但我太疼了，动不了。当我向前弯腰时，我听到它裂开得更厉害了。
I called my friend Andrea sobbing. She was at my apartment within five minutes. She came in holding a bottle of white wine and two Valiums-- one for her, one for me. She had me lay back and pushed wads of gauze in my leg crease like she was putting the stuffing back in a teddy bear. But even surgery couldn't remove the extra skin entirely. When I hold my arms and legs out, I still look like a flying squirrel.
我哭着给我的朋友安德烈娅打电话。她五分钟内就到了我的公寓。她进来时拿着一瓶白葡萄酒和两片安定——一个给她，一个给我。她让我躺下，把纱布塞进我的大腿褶皱里，就像在给泰迪熊塞填充物一样。但即使是手术也无法完全去除多余的皮肤。当我把手臂和腿伸开时，我看起来还是像只飞鼠。
Here's a journal entry from when I was 22. Quote, "I was happy when I was overweight. I had no idea I should be sad. I was free before. I had trained myself not to care what people thought, and I'd done a good job of it. I learned how to do the worm, and I would do it in dance circles. Only I wasn't actually physically capable of it. I just thought it was funny, and it made everyone laugh.
这是我22岁时的一则日记。引用，“我超重时很快乐。我根本不知道我应该悲伤。我以前是自由的。我训练自己不在乎人们怎么想，而且我做得很好。我学会了跳蠕动舞，我会在舞池里跳。只是我身体上并没有那个能力。我只是觉得它很有趣，让大家都笑了。”
I would never do that now. What if I look stupid? I wore the most ridiculously bold things-- vintage neon green and pink Hawaiian print dresses. I didn't constantly take the temperature of the room. It just was. That's the person I sold out to become this person.
“如果现在我绝对不会那样做。如果看起来很蠢怎么办？我穿了最荒谬大胆的东西——复古霓虹绿和粉色夏威夷印花裙。我不会不断地观察房间的气氛。它就是存在。这就是我出卖自己从而变成现在这个人的代价。”
As new Elna, I threw out all my pictures of old Elna and all the pictures in my parents' photo albums too, because I didn't want people to see them. And when I looked at those photos, they made me feel bad, because in the pictures, I looked happy. And I'd look at them and think, you're so stupid to think that you're happy. That's crazy, of course. And now I don't have any pictures of myself from ages 12 to 22.
作为新埃尔娜，我扔掉了所有旧埃尔娜的照片，甚至把我父母相册里的所有照片也扔了，因为我不想让人们看到它们。当我看着那些照片时，它们让我感到难受，因为在照片里，我看起来很快乐。我会看着它们心想，你真是笨到以为自己很快乐。这太疯狂了，当然。现在我一张12岁到22岁之间的照片都没有了。
As new Elna, I once went on a date with a cute guy who said to me, I know this is going to sound mean, but I just can't tolerate fat people, and then took my hand for the very first time. And I held his hand. I said nothing. I didn't tell him about old Elna. We went for a walk. I went out with him again. It's sad that new Elna gets everything old Elna wanted, because I think old Elna was a better person than new Elna.
作为新埃尔娜，我曾和一个可爱的男人约会，他对我说，我知道这听起来很刻薄，但我无法容忍胖子，然后第一次拉住了我的手。我握住了他的手。我什么都没说。我没告诉他旧埃尔娜的事。我们去散步了。我又和他出去了。新埃尔娜得到了旧埃尔娜想要的一切，这很悲哀，因为我认为旧埃尔娜比新埃尔娜更好。
Recently I read Lindy West's book. She's my same age. We both grew up in Seattle. We're the same height and used to be the same weight. And she stayed fat and decided she was happy with it. She got everything I thought I had to lose over 100 pounds to get.
最近我读了琳迪·韦斯特的书。她和我同岁。我们都在西雅图长大。我们身高相同，曾经体重也相同。她保持了肥胖，并决定对此感到快乐。她得到了我认为我必须减掉100多磅才能得到的一切。
Sarai Walker's book Dietland hit me just as hard. I related more to those books than any I've ever read. In each of them, a fat woman grappled with the same things I did and made the opposite choice. They stayed fat. And reading these two books was the first time I was able to imagine a parallel universe where I could have stayed fat.
萨莱·沃克的书《节食之地》也让我深受触动。相比我读过的任何书，我与这些书产生了更多的共鸣。在每一本书中，一个胖女人都处理了我处理过的事情，并做出了相反的选择。她们保持了肥胖。阅读这两本书是我第一次能够想象一个我可以一直胖下去的平行宇宙。
For the first time, I wondered if I had done the right thing by killing off old Elna. I've been honestly in a bit of a crisis. I started recording a conversation with my husband a few weeks ago about some of this to help think through the ideas of this story. I do that a lot. He and I have only been married a month. He never met old Elna. And we were talking about fat and beauty and how important beauty is for men. And it got really emotional really fast.
这是第一次，我想知道杀死旧埃尔娜是否是正确的决定。我坦率地说一直处于一种危机中。几周前，我开始录制我和丈夫关于其中一些内容的对话，以帮助思考这个故事的想法。我经常这么做。他和我也才结婚一个月。他从没见过旧埃尔娜。我们在谈论肥胖和美，以及美对男人来说有多重要。结果很快变得非常情绪化。
--to be that. You would never have been attracted to me before. You know that makes me really sad? Oh, my god.
——是那样的。你以前永远不会被我吸引。你知道这让我很难过吗？哦，天哪。
I mean, you married someone that wouldn't have been attracted to  you?
我的意思是，你娶了一个以前根本不会被你吸引的人？
Who wouldn't have loved me. You would never have talked-- I mean, you would have talked to me. We would have been friends. But you wouldn't have ever dated me, ever.
一个根本不会爱我的人。你永远不会谈——我的意思是，你会跟我说话。我们本来会是朋友。但你永远不会约我出去，永远不会。
Yeah, but you know what's funny? There's something about you--
是啊，但你知道什么很有趣吗？你身上有些东西——
He changes the subject to disillusionment in general, says what I'm realizing is the same thing every teenager realizes in every John Hughes movie-- that the world is unfair. I'm not having it.
他把话题转向了普遍的幻灭，说我正在意识到和约翰·休斯每部电影里每个青少年意识到的一样的事情——世界是不公平的。我才不要。
Can I go back a second?
我能回头一下吗？
Yeah, how far back?
好的，回多少？
I actually have never said it. But I said to you that you wouldn't have been attracted to me.
我其实从没说过。但我对你说过你不会被我吸引。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
That's true, right?
那是真的，对吧？
What do you mean?
你的意思是？
It's true.
那是真的。
That would I have dated fat Elna?
即我会约会胖埃尔娜吗？
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
I don't know. Probably not.
我不知道。可能不会。
Yeah. OK.
是的。好的。
This makes us both pause.
这让我们俩都停顿了。
So we're a newlywed couple.
所以我们是一对新婚夫妇。
Married for two weeks.
结婚两周。
Not even. How long have  we been married? 10 days?
还没到。我们结婚多久了？10天？
10 days.
10天。
[CHUCKLE]
[轻笑]
And we're realizing that our marriage is based on a lie.
我们意识到我们的婚姻建立在谎言之上。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
It was a joke, of course, our marriage based on a lie. Ha, ha, ha. But then there's this.
那是个笑话，当然，我们的婚姻建立在谎言之上。哈哈哈哈。但后来有了这个。
I've always said I think the real you is the skinny you.
我一直说我认为真实的你是瘦的你。
That's stupid.
那是蠢话。
Not the skinny you, but the real--
不是瘦的你，而是真实的——
No, that's not even true. I think the real--
不，那甚至不是真的。我认为真实的——
This argument over which is the real me, old Elna or new Elna, goes on for days.
这场关于哪一个是真实我的争论，旧埃尔娜还是新埃尔娜，持续了好几天。
Well, then that's you.
嗯，那你就这样。
No, it's just--
不，那只是——
Here we are in a car. Mark explains that he doesn't think I became comfortable with myself until I was thin.
我们现在在车里。马克解释说他认为直到我变瘦，我才变得对自己感到舒适。
If this isn't-- no, no, no. No, no, no. Listen to me.
如果这不是——不，不，不。不，不，不。听我说。
I didn't feel like I'm comfortable in my body or my own skin before. It was just me.
我以前并不是对自己或自己的皮肤感到不舒服。那只是我。
I know, but if--
我知道，但如果——
It wasn't like I was--
我并不是——
If you feel like--
如果你觉得——
It wasn't like me in a fat suit. It was me. That's what I was. So I wasn't like, oh, this feels really big and uncomfortable. It just was me as a human. I was just a human. It was me.
那不是像我在穿胖子装一样。那就是我。这就是我。所以我不是说，哦，这感觉又大又不舒服。那只是作为一个人的我。我只是一个人。那就是我。
I know, but you--
我知道，但你——
What Mark doesn't understand is that my old body doesn't feel that far away. What he's rejecting is me. I could gain weight so easily. I mean, what if we have kids? But we're working on it. He told me recently he knows he hasn't been listening.
马克不明白的是，我旧的身体感觉并没有那么远。他在拒绝的是我。我很容易增重。我的意思是，如果我们有孩子怎么办？但我们正在努力。他最近告诉我，他知道他一直没在听。
And for my part, I see how so much of love is physical attraction, especially at the beginning. It's not the story we're told. It's not the one I wanted to believe. But it's a story I can live with.
就我而言，我看到爱在很大程度上是身体上的吸引，特别是在开始的时候。这不是人们告诉我们的故事。这不是我想要相信的那个。但这是一个我可以接受的故事。
Here's something I never tell people. I still take phentermine. I take it for a few months at a time a year, or sometimes it feels like half of the year. I can't get it prescribed anymore, so I buy it in Mexico or online, though the online stuff is fake and doesn't work as well.
这里有一件事我从不告诉别人。我仍然服用芬特明。我一年里会吃几个月，有时感觉像是半年。我不能再凭处方拿药了，所以我从墨西哥或网上买，尽管网上的那些是假的，也没那么管用。
I have a shirt that says, "I'm allergic to mornings." Everyone who knows me knows I have problems sleeping at night. I am usually up until 4:00 AM. I say I have insomnia. Really, I am awake because I am on speed. And I am on speed, because I need to stay thin. I need to stay thin so I can get what I want.
我有一件衬衫，上面写着：“我对早晨过敏。”认识我的人都知道我晚上睡觉有问题。我通常熬到凌晨4点。我说我有失眠症。实际上，我清醒是因为我在服用兴奋剂。我在服用兴奋剂，因为我需要保持瘦。我需要保持瘦，这样我才能得到我想要的。
I know how this sounds. I know exactly how messed up it is. But I also feel like I can't be honest with you, like we won't really get anywhere unless I admit it. I'm taking it right now, by the way. I took it at 11:00 AM this morning. I will take another one at 4:00. I was on it to lose weight for my wedding. And now I'm still on it because I'm about to pitch a TV show in LA, and I need to lose even more weight.
我知道这听起来怎么样。我完全知道这有多么糟糕。但我也觉得我不能对你诚实，就像除非我承认它，否则我们真的哪里也去不了。顺便说一句，我现在正在吃。我今天早上11点吃的。我4点会再吃一片。我在为婚礼减肥时一直在吃。现在我还在吃，因为我正要在洛杉矶推销一个电视节目，我需要再减掉一些体重。
Phentermine turns off the part of my brain that thinks about food. When I'm on it, I can legitimately say, I forgot to eat. I've thought before that it may be affecting my health. It feels that way. I've intentionally never googled the side effects.
芬特明关掉了我大脑里考虑食物的那部分。当我在吃它时，我可以理直气壮地说，我忘了吃饭。我以前认为这可能正在影响我的健康。感觉确实如此。我有意从未谷歌搜索过副作用。
I know that all of this is wrong. I don't like what I am. But I've accepted it as part of the deal.
我知道这一切都是错的。我不喜欢现在的我。但我已经接受它作为交易的一部分。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, does God want you thin? Some people think so. Grab a Twinkie and come back in a minute, Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，上帝想让你瘦吗？有些人这么认为。抓个零食，一分钟后回来，芝加哥公共广播，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Tell Me I'm Fat," in which we ask, should we think about weight differently than we do? We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, How You Doing with Sizes?
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，“告诉我我很胖”，在节目中我们问，我们是否应该以不同于现在的方式看待体重？我们已经到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，你的尺寸怎么样？
So obesity in America affects a higher percentage of black people than white people. Roxane Gay has written a lot about race and some about obesity in her book Bad Feminist and elsewhere. Roxane's black. She's fat. And she says those two things together have a huge impact on the way people perceive her.
所以美国的肥胖影响了比白人更高百分比的黑人。罗珊·盖伊在她的书《坏女权主义者》和其他地方写了很多关于种族和肥胖的文章。罗珊是黑人。她很胖。她说这两点加在一起对人们看待她的方式产生了巨大的影响。
Oh, I'm mistaken for a man all the time. Literally all the time. And I'm sorry, but I have huge breasts. There's just no way that you're mistaking me for a man. It's because they see me, and they see my skin. And they think, well, no, she can't possibly be a woman. And so that's the number one thing that happens, and it's actually extremely annoying.
哦，我总是被误认为是男人。字面上一直都是。我很抱歉，但我有巨大的乳房。你根本没理由把我误认为是男人。那是因为他们看见我，看见我的皮肤。他们心想，好吧，不，她不可能是女人。所以这是发生的第一件事，实际上非常烦人。
And it's white people, or it's black people also?
那是白人，还是黑人也是？
Oh, no, it's white people. Black people know what I am.
哦，不，那是白人。黑人知道我是什么。
You said being black adds another layer of bullshit to being overweight.
你说身为黑人又为超重增加了一层屁话。
Yes, it does, like you're even lower on the sort of totem pole of dignity. People look right past you, and they don't think that you have anything of value to offer. Like, you can go into a car dealership, for example. And you're the very last person that the dealer will walk up to, because they think you can't buy a car.
是的，它确实，就像你在尊严的图腾柱上更低了。人们直接看穿你，他们认为你没有任何价值可提供。比如，你可以走进一家汽车经销店。你是经销商最后才会走向的人，因为他们认为你买不起车。
Has that happened to you at a car dealership?
这在汽车经销店发生在你身上过吗？
Yeah, definitely. You know, I think the thing that happens most commonly is when I'm flying, I am oftentimes standing in the priority line, because I travel every week. And people will say, you know, this is the first-class line, as if I don't belong there.
是的，绝对发生过。你知道，我想最常发生的事情是当我飞行时，我经常站在优先通道，因为我每周都旅行。人们会说，你知道，这是头等舱通道，就好像我不属于那里一样。
What do you say?
你怎么说？
I say I know how to read and just leave it at that.
我说我知道怎么识字，就这样。
You draw a distinction among different kinds of fatness. Can I have you talk about that?
你在不同种类的肥胖之间做出了区分。能让我谈谈那个吗？
Yeah, I mean, I think there are different kinds of fatness. There's the person who's maybe 20 pounds overweight, who's fine as they are. But if they want to lose weight, they just need to go on Slim Fast for a couple weeks or something.
是的，我的意思是，我认为有不同种类的肥胖。有一种超重20磅的人，他们现在的样子很好。但如果他们想减肥，他们只需要喝几周减肥奶昔之类的东西。
And then you have people who are-- I  like to call them Lane Bryant fat, which means they can still buy clothes at Lane Bryant, which goes up to 28 in size. And they're the ones I find that are often the strongest cheerleaders of, this is who I am, and, you have to take me as I am and respect me because of my body not despite it. And I admire that a great deal. But I think it's easier to feel that way when you have multiple places where you can buy clothes and feel pretty and move through the world.
然后你有——我喜欢称他们为“Lane Bryant胖”的人，这意味着他们仍然可以在Lane Bryant买衣服，那是大码服装，最高到28码。我发现他们通常是“这就是我，你必须接受我，尊重我是因为我的身体，而不是尽管我的身体”最坚定的支持者。我非常钦佩这一点。但我认为当你拥有多个地方可以买衣服、感到漂亮并在这个世界上走动时，感觉会更容易。
And you noted, Lindy is what you call Lane Bryant fat. She told me she was a size 22.
你提到了，琳迪就是你所说的“Lane Bryant胖”。她告诉我她是22码。
Yeah, I mean, and I don't mean that in a disrespectful way. I just mean she has access to spaces that people like me do not.
是的，我的意思是，我不是以不尊重的方式说。我只是指她有进入像我这样的人无法进入的空间的途径。
Because what's your situation?
因为你的情况是什么？
There's another level. I mean, then there's when you're super morbidly obese, where you can't really even find stores that can accommodate you. You don't fit in any public spaces, like movie theaters, public bathrooms, so on and so forth.
还有另一个层面。我的意思是，当你处于超级病态肥胖时，你甚至找不到能容纳你的商店。你不适合任何公共空间，比如电影院、公共厕所等等。
Is the official name of what you are morbidly obese? That's the medical term?
你这种情况的正式名称是病态肥胖吗？那是医学术语？
No, the medical term is super morbidly obese.
不，医学术语是超级病态肥胖。
It's so mean.
太刻薄了。
Yes, it is. It's mean. It's dehumanizing.
是的，确实如此。这很刻薄。这是去人性化。
How much weight would you have to lose to be Lane Bryant fat?
你要减掉多少体重才能变成“Lane Bryant胖”？
200 pounds.
200磅。
You've said this thing-- fat is all I ever think about, and it's exhausting. What are you talking about? What do you mean?
你说过这样一句话——肥胖是我唯一想到的事，这让人精疲力竭。你在说什么？你的意思是什么？
I'm just hyper-obsessed. This whole nonstop anxiety conversation happens in my head all the time for just basic life functions, like, oh, I have to go do this, you know? Before I will go out to eat, I research a restaurant extensively on Google. And I look at Google Images. And I make sure, are the chairs solid? Do they have arms? What does the dining room look like? And if I don't think I'm going to be comfortable, I simply won't go.
我只是极度痴迷。这种不间断的焦虑对话一直在我的脑海里发生，为了基本的生命功能，比如，哦，我必须去做这个，你知道吗？在我出去吃饭之前，我会在谷歌上详尽地研究一家餐馆。我会看谷歌图片。我确保，椅子稳固吗？它们有扶手吗？餐厅看起来怎么样？如果我觉得我不会舒服，我就干脆不去。
It's sobering to realize just how the past 25 years have just been all about my body. And that's where I struggle with the fat acceptance movement. I think it's wonderful, and I think it's necessary and a necessary corrective.
意识到过去25年全都关于我的身体是令人清醒的。这就是我在肥胖接受运动中挣扎的地方。我认为它很棒，我认为它是必要的，是一个必要的矫正。
But not all of us of have been able to get to that space where we don't care what other people think. I'm not all there yet, and I'm trying. But it's just really hard to not care what people think, especially when they're constantly telling you what they think.
但并非我们所有人都能达到那种不在乎别人怎么想的空间。我还没完全到那里，但我正在努力。但真的很难不在乎别人怎么想，特别是当他们不断告诉你他们怎么想的时候。
But part of it is being able to say, I feel good and fine about looking this way and being this way. And it seems like when I read you, I feel like, oh, well, that's a huge part of what you actually don't want to accept. You're saying, I happen to be this way, but I don't want to be this way. So why do I have to pretend that I'm OK with it?
但其中一部分是能够说，我对现在的样子和现在的状态感到良好和没问题。当我读你的文字时，我感觉，哦，好吧，那是你其实不想接受的部分的重要组成。你说，我碰巧是这样，但我不想这样。所以我为什么要假装我对此没问题？
Exactly. I don't want to pretend that I'm OK with it, and it's not judging anyone else. It's just that I know the realities of living in my body. I know how irritating and how exhausting it is to, for example, climb a set of stairs. And so I don't need to be thin, but I want to be in better shape. I want to have more stamina. And I honestly, because I'm vain, want to wear cuter clothes.
完全正确。我不想假装我对它没问题，而且这不是在评判别人。只是我知道生活在我的身体里的现实。我知道爬楼梯是多么令人恼火和精疲力竭。所以我不需要变瘦，但我想要更好的体型。我想要更多的耐力。而且我老实说，因为我虚荣，我想穿更可爱的衣服。
That's normal.
那是正常的。
Yeah, it is normal. But then there's a lot of people who don't like that attitude in me. But again, I think it's because they're Lane Bryant fat. And even when you're Lane Bryant fat, it's a struggle. But at least you have that. I don't even have that. And so it's like, let me feel the way I want to feel. Just let me be me.
是的，很正常。但很多人不喜欢我这种态度。但同样，我认为这是因为他们是“Lane Bryant胖”。即使你是“Lane Bryant胖”，也是一种挣扎。但至少你有那个。我甚至连那个都没有。所以就像，让我以我想要的方式去感受。只让我做我自己吧。
Roxane Gay. She's currently writing a book about being fat. It's called Hunger . By the way, we double-checked with Lane Bryant. This doesn't change Roxane's point at all, but they go up to 32.
罗珊·盖伊。她目前正在写一本关于肥胖的书。它叫《饥饿》。顺便说一句，我们和Lane Bryant再次核实了一下。这完全不改变罗珊的观点，但他们的尺码最高可达32码。
Act Four, Cross Trainers. It's so common to judge people on their weight. And of course, so often there is this moral dimension to it that is just gross-- this idea that you're fat because you're weak, you can't get control of your own life.
第四幕，交叉训练者。用体重来评判人太普遍了。当然，通常会有这种道德层面，这太恶心了——这种认为你胖是因为你软弱，你无法控制自己生活的观念。
Today on our program, we're saying maybe that is not the most accurate or the most helpful way to look at this. This next story is about a very specialized example of this kind of moralism. You may know that there's a Christian weight loss movement. And it's big, with seminars and books like Help Lord, the Devil Wants Me Fat . Daniel Engber takes us into to a particularly extreme moment for this movement.
今天在我们的节目中，我们在说也许这不是看待这件事最准确或最有帮助的方式。下一个故事是这种道德主义的一个非常特殊的例子。你可能知道有一个基督教减肥运动。而且它很大，有研讨会和像《主啊救救我，魔鬼想让我变胖》这样的书。丹尼尔·恩格伯带我们进入了这个运动一个特别极端的时刻。
Paul Brynteson loves to exercise. He's a runner. He's a biker. He's actually got a doctorate in physical education. And he spent a big portion of his life teaching people how to stay in shape. In the early 1970s, Paul got this dream job offer.
保罗·布林特森喜欢运动。他是跑步者。他是骑行者。他实际上拥有体育教育博士学位。他一生中很大一部分时间都在教人们如何保持身材。70年代初，保罗得到了这份梦寐以求的工作机会。
He got a call from the brand-new Oral Roberts University asking him to head up their new phys ed program. Paul was a Pentecostal Evangelical Christian. And Oral Roberts was maybe the most famous televangelist and faith healer in the world. Two of the biggest things in Paul's life were coming together-- God and exercise. So Paul and his wife moved out to Tulsa.
他接到了全新的奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学的电话，请他领导他们新的体育教育计划。保罗是一位五旬节派福音派基督徒。而奥罗尔·罗伯茨可能是世界上最著名的电视福音传道者和信仰治疗师。保罗生命中最重要的两件事汇聚在一起——上帝和运动。所以保罗和他的妻子搬到了塔尔萨。
When I arrived at Oral Roberts University, within a month, he met with all the new faculty. And I remember sitting across from him in his home having dinner. And I asked him the question, why is physical fitness so important to you?
当我到达奥罗尔·罗伯茨大学时，不到一个月，他会见了所有新教员。我记得坐在他家里和他共进晚餐。我问了他一个问题，为什么身体健康对你来说如此重要？
Because I was aware of the whole Pentecostal fundamentalist movement of Christianity, and exercise was not a part of that environment. And so I wondered, why was it important to Oral Roberts? And his response, I thought, was really interesting.
因为我知道整个五旬节派原教旨主义基督教运动，而运动并不是那个环境的一部分。所以我很好奇，为什么它对奥罗尔·罗伯茨如此重要？我觉得他的回答真的很有趣。
Now, he was a faith healer. He had traveled the world for those 25 years before we got there praying for the sick. And so he told me. He said, I've probably laid my hands and prayed for over a million-- well over a million-- people. And as I did that, little by little, I observed that I think I wouldn't have to pray for the healing and health of these individuals if they would just take care of themselves.
现在，他是一位信仰治疗师。在我们去那里之前的25年里，他走遍世界为病人祈祷。所以他告诉我。他说，我可能已经按手并为超过一百万——超过一百万——人祈祷了。当我那样做时，一点一点地，我观察到我认为我不必为这些人的康复和健康祈祷，如果他们能照顾好自己的话。
Oral Roberts wanted to teach a lifestyle to his students, what he called the whole man philosophy-- mind, body, spirit. They would all have equal importance at the school. Here's how the provost from back then, Carl Hamilton, explains it now.
奥罗尔·罗伯茨想教给学生一种生活方式，他称之为“全人哲学”——思想、身体、精神。它们在学校里地位平等。当时的教务长卡尔·汉密尔顿现在是这样解释的。
Our bodies are the home of the Holy Spirit. Making that home a fit one is one of the ways to glorify God and the Holy Spirit.
我们的身体是圣灵的家。让这个家变得健康是荣耀上帝和圣灵的方式之一。
Paul would be in charge of making that home a fit one. In the fall of 1974, he took over the school's aerobics program at a brand new $2 million center with a fancy indoor track. Every student had to get a certain number of aerobics points per week. They might get a point for walking a mile or two for playing doubles tennis or five for bouncing on a trampoline.
保罗将负责让这个家变得健康。1974年秋天，他在一个全新的200万美元中心接管了学校的健美操项目，那里有一个漂亮的室内跑道。每个学生每周必须获得一定数量的健美操积分。他们可能会因为走一英里获得一分，或者因为打双打网球获得两分，或者因为在蹦床上蹦跳获得五分。
Remember, this is 40 years before Fitbits. Back in 1974, just the idea of regular exercise was cutting edge. Jogging had only just become a thing. Aerobics was brand new. And here was ORU with all its students running around in headbands and tube socks. Then Oral Roberts had another idea-- to push the fitness program even further. Here's Paul.
记住，这是在Fitbit出现前40年。早在1974年，仅仅定期运动的概念就是前沿的。慢跑才刚刚流行起来。健美操是全新的。在这里，ORU所有的学生都戴着头带和筒袜跑来跑去。然后奥罗尔·罗伯茨有了另一个想法——把健身计划推向更进一步。这是保罗。
At the graduation ceremonies of 1975, at the end of my first year there, Oral Roberts observed several students who graduated that he saw were obese. And within the next few days, he contacted Dr. Carl Hamilton, the provost of the university-- and this is, I understand, how this took place-- and said, I really don't want to see significantly overweight, obese students graduating, because it indicates that they have not met the goal of the university to be physically disciplined. And please develop some guidelines or some criteria so those students make progress or do not graduate. Maybe do not graduate is too strong a term, but that, , anyway, something is done about that.
在1975年的毕业典礼上，我第一年结束时，奥罗尔·罗伯茨观察到几个毕业的学生他认为很肥胖。接下来的几天里，他联系了卡尔·汉密尔顿医生，大学教务长——据我了解，事情是这样发生的——他说，我真的不想看到明显超重、肥胖的学生毕业，因为这表明他们没有达到学校身体自律的目标。请制定一些准则或标准，让这些学生取得进步或者不能毕业。也许“不能毕业”这个词太重了，但，无论如何，要做点什么。
In that moment, something changed. Paul's fitness program wouldn't just keep tabs on students' exercise. Now he'd make sure they weren't fat. Suddenly how you looked mattered.
那一刻，事情改变了。保罗的健身计划不仅会记录学生的运动。现在他要确保他们不胖。突然间，你的样子变得很重要了。
And so we began doing skin fold testing that fall.
所以那天秋天我们开始做皮褶测试。
Skin fold testing. Just to give you a sense of how serious ORU was about this and how ambitious, at the beginning of every semester, every freshman went to what they called the human performance lab for skin fold testing. They were tested on a bunch of stuff-- their lipid levels, their lung capacity, and their body fat. First, they take a caliper to the thigh.
皮褶测试。为了让你了解ORU对此有多认真以及多有野心，每个学期开始时，每个新生都要去他们所谓的“人体表现实验室”进行皮褶测试。他们会被测试很多东西——他们的血脂水平、肺活量和体脂。首先，他们用卡尺夹在大腿上。
In the abdomen, in the back, in the triceps area.
在腹部、背部、三头肌区域。
And then in certain cases, they checked their measurements by dunking students in a giant bathtub. That was the gold standard for determining body fat in the 1970s.
然后在某些情况下，他们通过把学生浸入一个巨大的浴缸里来检查测量结果。那是70年代测定体脂的金标准。
So they put you in a bathing suit, right? So the least amount of clothing that you can get away with. And of course, it was a Christian university, so it was almost like a turtleneck bathing suit, right?
所以他们让你穿上泳衣，对吧？也就是你能穿的最少衣服。而且当然，这是一所基督教大学，所以它几乎就像一件高领泳衣，对吧？
Jerri Johnston was one of the students in Paul's new program. She says her fat test was like being in a carnival dunk tank.
杰里·约翰斯顿是保罗新计划的学生之一。她说她的胖测试就像在嘉年华的落水桶里一样。
They would put you on this chair and lower you into the water-filled-- I would just call it-- it was almost like they were putting you in a big beaker. You know what I'm saying? And it would have water in it, and they would put you in the water. And they would tell you-- up to your neck. And they would say, blow out as much air as you can and then hold your breath as long as you can. And then they would put you on in the water. And then they would--
他们会把你放在椅子上，降低到充满水的桶里——我只会称它为——几乎就像他们把你放进一个大烧杯里。你知道我在说什么吗？里面会有水，他们会把你放进水里。他们会告诉你——直到脖子。他们会说，尽可能呼出空气，然后尽可能久地屏住呼吸。然后他们会把你浸在水里。然后他们会——
You were completely submerged?
你完全被淹没了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, well--
我的意思是，好吧——
You know--
你知道——
Did all of the students have to do that?
所有学生都必须那样做吗？
I don't think so. I think just the people that were in-- just us special ones.
我不这么认为。我觉得只是那些在——只是我们这些特殊的。
Jerri Johnston was too big. Students like her were put onto something called the Pounds Off plan. It all came down to their percentage body fat.
杰里·约翰斯顿太胖了。像她这样的学生被列入了所谓的“减磅计划”。这一切都归结为他们的体脂百分比。
25% for males and 35% for females would be a good cutoff.
男性25%，女性35%将是一个很好的截止点。
And then they had to lose some weight. Specifically, lose 8 pounds each semester and 1% body fat. This wasn't a suggestion. It was a requirement. The school told Jerri at the end of sophomore year that she'd have to keep on losing weight. She'd have to weigh 180 pounds by the time that she came back in the fall.
然后他们不得不减掉一些体重。具体来说，每个学期减掉8磅和1%的体脂。这不是建议。这是要求。大二学期末，学校告诉杰里，她必须继续减肥。等到秋天回来的时候，她必须体重达到180磅。
Well, we came on campus. And so my roommate was there, and then my friend was there. And so I was like, oh. And then I said, let me go over. I have to go over the lab. We had to check in over there.
嗯，我们来到校园。室友在那，朋友在那。我当时想，噢。然后我说，让我过去。我得去实验室。我们必须在那里签到。
The human performance lab?
人体表现实验室？
Yeah, and check in. And then I'll be back, and we'll unpack and everything.
是的，签到。然后我会回来，我们 unpack 和所有事情。
When she stepped on the scale, she came in at 184, 4 pounds too heavy.
当她踩上秤时，她是184磅，重了4磅。
And they said, you're over this weight. We want you to go home and try to get the weight off this semester. And then you're welcome to come back next semester if you make the weight.
他们说，你体重超标了。我们希望你回家，尝试在这个学期减掉体重。如果你达到体重，欢迎你下学期回来。
She'd have to go back to the dorm, say goodbye to her roommates, and go home. She'd been suspended for being fat.
她不得不回宿舍，跟室友道别，然后回家。她因为肥胖被停学了。
And I was astonished. And then they prayed with us. I was like, OK. And then--
我惊呆了。然后他们为我们祈祷。我当时想，好吧。然后——
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉声音]
They told you that in front of your parents, and then you all prayed together with your parents.
他们在你父母面前告诉你的，然后你们和父母一起祈祷了。
Well, I was praying. My dad might have been acting like he was praying, because he was pretty upset that somebody was treating me like that. And so when I got back in the dorm and I was talking to my roommates and stuff, they were like, well, you can do it. You know, we'll pray for you this semester.
好吧，我在祈祷。我爸爸可能表现得像他在祈祷，因为他对有人那样对待我很生气。当我回到宿舍，跟室友谈论这件事时，她们就像，嗯，你可以做到的。你知道，我们这个学期会为你祈祷的。
And I was just pretty devastated for the first couple of months that, you know, that that was the only thing that seemed to be important, right? What I look like and not what kind of person I was. And it was kind of a disclaimer of everything that a Christian university was supposed to be about, right?
前几个月我感到非常沮丧，只有那件事看起来很重要，对吧？我看起来怎么样，而不是我是一个什么样的人。而且这算是一个基督教大学应该关心的所有事情的免责声明，对吧？
I was like, really, God? Is this how you're judging people? I don't know how they reconcile that, you know? The thing is supposed to be, God looks inside and sees your heart, right? That's the premise. And that's how it's supposed to be.
我当时想，真的吗，上帝？这就是你评判人的方式吗？我不知道他们怎么能调和这一点，你知道吗？事情应该是，上帝看着内心并看到你的心，对吧？那是前提。而且它应该就是那样。
In 1977, word got out about the Pounds Off program to people who didn't go to Oral Roberts.
1977年，关于“减磅计划”的消息传到了那些不去奥罗尔·罗伯茨的人耳中。
The university wants to know what percentage of a student's weight is fat.
大学想知道学生体重的百分之几是脂肪。
The Today Show , ABC, the BBC-- news crews arrived on campus to film the students doing their aerobics and sit in on special lectures for the fat kids.
《今日秀》、ABC、BBC——新闻摄制组抵达校园，拍摄学生做健美操，并参加为胖孩子举办的特别讲座。
You know, in the book of Romans, Paul says that all-- 8:28's the verse in case you want to look it up-- all things work together for good to those that love God, who are the called according to His purpose. Now, my goodness, how can anything like fat be good? And how can God have purpose in a person being fat?
你知道，在《罗马书》中，保罗说一切——如果你想查的话，是8:28节——万事都互相效力，叫爱上帝的人得益处，就是按祂旨意被召的人。现在，天哪，肥胖怎么能是好事情？上帝怎么能在一个人肥胖中赋予目的？
In one report, the camera shows this guy, an overweight student, sitting shirtless in the lab. A woman in a white coat grabs his belly fat with a set of calipers during the interview.
在一篇报道中，摄像机展示了这个家伙，一个超重的学生，赤裸着上身坐在实验室里。采访期间，一个穿白大褂的女人用一套卡尺抓住他的腹部脂肪。
How much weight have you lost in this Pounds Off program?
你在“减磅计划”中减掉了多少体重？
I've lost 25 pounds since last summer, Julie.
自去年夏天以来，我减掉了25磅，朱莉。
And what do you think about that?
你对此怎么看？
Well, I'm thrilled with it. It's changed my life already. I didn't have the incentive without this program to do it on my own. In fact, without this program, I don't think I could survive, because I'd feel like-- I've just been reborn, actually.
嗯，我很兴奋。它已经改变了我的生活。没有这个计划，我没有动力靠自己做到。事实上，没有这个计划，我不认为我能活下来，因为我会觉得——我其实已经重生了。
Born again by losing weight. The newscasters made it seem like this was some crazy Christian thing. But it wasn't really all that strange. Paul Brynteson may have taught what he called God's diet plan to the kids at Oral Roberts.
通过减肥重生。新闻播音员让它看起来像是某种疯狂的基督教东西。但它其实没那么奇怪。保罗·布林特森可能在奥罗尔·罗伯茨教孩子们他所谓的上帝的饮食计划。
But by the mid-'70s, diet plans were as ubiquitous as they are today. Then, as now, being fat was not just seen by lots of people as a medical failing, but a moral one. That if you're fat, you must be lazy or lack self-discipline, that there's something wrong with our country that so many of us can't control our weight. As I looked into the history of weight loss culture, I came across this amazing tape of John F. Kennedy from a speech he gave on child welfare in 1962 and sounding not so different from Oral Roberts.
但到了70年代中期，饮食计划像今天一样无处不在。那时和现在一样，肥胖不仅被很多人视为医学失败，还被视为道德失败。如果你胖，你一定是懒惰或缺乏自律，国家一定出了什么问题，导致我们这么多人无法控制体重。当我深入研究减肥文化的历史时，我发现了约翰·F·肯尼迪1962年关于儿童福利演讲中的这段精彩录音，听起来和奥罗尔·罗伯茨没多大区别。
There is nothing, I think, more unfortunate than to have soft, chubby, fat-looking children who go to watch their school play basketball every Saturday and regard that as their week's exercise.
没有什么比拥有柔软、胖乎乎、看起来肥胖的孩子更不幸的了，他们每周六去看学校打篮球，并把这当作他们一周的锻炼。
But as people grew more obsessed with being thin, there was a backlash. So when the Pounds Off program started making headlines, plenty of people said it was discrimination. And plenty of others said basically, sure, it's discrimination but in a good way, like it could inspire lazy people to get in shape. The ACLU got involved. Paul was shaken up. He talked to my producer Zoe about this.
但随着人们越来越痴迷于变瘦，出现了反弹。所以当“减磅计划”开始登上头条时，很多人说那是歧视。还有很多人基本上说，当然，这是歧视，但这是好的歧视，比如它能激励懒人保持身材。美国公民自由联盟介入了。保罗被震住了。他跟我的制作人佐伊谈到了这件事。
Were you afraid it would be hurtful to them?
你担心这会伤害他们吗？
Yes. That's a really good way to put it.
是的。那是一个很好的表达方式。
What were you nervous about?
你紧张什么？
I think every individual is different. For some individuals, I suppose if they were four pounds over and they didn't meet a goal that they were supposed to meet, not allowing them back in school-- for some individuals that could be a turning point where they could change their life around, and that would never happen again.
我认为每个人都是不同的。对于有些人，我假设如果他们超重4磅，而没达到应该达到的目标，不让他们回学校——对于有些人那可能是一个转折点，他们可以改变生活，以后再也不会发生。
For other individuals, that can be a devastating experience that they never recover from. And who's to know which way that decision is going to go? And so at this point in my life, I'd say I would err on the side of, let's not hurt somebody.
对于其他人，那可能是一个他们永远无法恢复的毁灭性经历。谁知道那个决定会走向哪边？所以在生命的这个阶段，我会说我会宁愿犯错在，“让我们不要伤害某人”这一边。
Oral Roberts still has a physical fitness requirement. Students there still have to collect aerobics points. But they're not required to lose weight. When we asked the school about the Pounds Off program, the current administration said they hadn't heard of it. They said it was super difficult to comprehend that such a thing had existed. But I don't think it's difficult at all. Stuff like this is all around us. Oral Roberts just made it more explicit.
奥罗尔·罗伯茨仍然有身体健康要求。那里的学生仍然必须收集健美操积分。但他们不需要减肥。当我们问学校关于“减磅计划”时，现在的管理层说他们没听说过。他们说理解竟然存在过这样的事是超级困难的。但我认为一点也不难。像这样的东西在我们身边随处可见。奥罗尔·罗伯茨只是让它更显性了。
Daniel Engber. He writes about obesity for Slate magazine and The New York Times .
丹尼尔·恩格伯。他为《Slate》杂志和《纽约时报》写关于肥胖的文章。
[MUSIC - BETTY FORD BOYS, "PHYSICAL FITNESS"]
[音乐 - 贝蒂福特男孩，“身体健康”]
Act Five, An Immodest Proposal. So here in the podcast and the internet version of our radio show this week, we are adding this. I just thought it would be nice to end the show with one last anecdote from Lindy West's book. And this is kind of an uplifting one. I hope that's not bad to say.
第五幕，一个不谦虚的建议。所以在这个播客和我们电台节目的网络版中，我们本周加上了这个。我只是认为在节目结束时用琳迪·韦斯特书中的最后一个轶事会很好。这是一种令人振奋的轶事。希望这样说没什么不好。
Lindy is married to this guy, Aham, and raising his kids with him. And as she points out in the book, he is conventionally handsome, very tall. And when the two of them are out together, sometimes people assume that because he is slim and good-looking and she is fat that they're not a couple.
琳迪嫁给了一个叫阿罕的家伙，并和他一起抚养孩子。正如她在书中指出的，他长得非常帅，很高。当他们俩一起出去时，有时人们认为因为他苗条帅气而她是胖子，所以他们不是一对。
Even if they're at a bar holding hands, looking exactly like a couple, people say stuff to them like, so you guys roommates? Women hit on him in front of Lindy. She read for me-- and this is what we're going to close out with today-- the story of their engagement.
即使他们在酒吧里牵着手，看起来完全像一对夫妇，人们也会对他们说，“你们是室友？”女性在琳迪面前勾引他。她为我读了——这就是我们今天结束的部分——他们订婚的故事。
Aham took me out for dinner on my 32nd birthday, then suggested a quick nightcap at our neighborhood bar. Everyone was there. It was a surprise. Our friends, our families, the kids, a cake. Aham took my hand and led me to the back. There was a paper banner that said my name.
阿罕带我出去庆祝我32岁生日，然后建议在我们社区的酒吧喝一杯。每个人都在那。那是个惊喜。我们的朋友、家人、孩子，一个蛋糕。阿罕拉着我的手领我到后面。那里有一张写着我名字的纸横幅。
Our friends Evan and Sam were playing a duet on cello and bass. I was confused. Why were there somber strings at my birthday party? Why was Aham doing intense face? Wait, it's almost 10:00 PM on a school night, and we're at a bar. Why are the kids here?
我们的朋友埃文和萨姆正在大提琴和贝斯上合奏。我困惑了。为什么我的生日派对上有阴郁的弦乐？为什么阿罕表情那么紧张？等等，这几乎是晚上10点，是一个上学的夜晚，我们却在酒吧。为什么孩子们在这里？
Then it all happened at once-- the knee, the ring, the speech, the question, the tears-- all the hits. It was a full-blown grand gesture. Later, I asked him why he did it that way-- such a big spectacle, such an event, not precisely our style. And I expected something cliche but sweet like, "I wanted to make sure our community was part of our marriage," or, "I wanted everyone to know how much I love you."
然后一切同时发生了——膝盖、戒指、演说、问题、泪水——所有的热门戏码。那是一个十足的大手笔。后来，我问他为什么那样做——那么大的场面，那么大一个事件，不完全是我们的风格。我期待着一些老套但甜蜜的话，比如，“我想确保我们的社区是我们婚姻的一部分”，或者，“我想让每个人都知道我有多爱你。”
Instead, he said, one time, when you were drunk, you told me, "if you ever propose to me, don't do it in the bullshit way that dudes usually treat fat girls-- like it's a secret, or you're just trying to keep me from leaving you. Thin girls get public proposals, like those dudes are winning a fucking prize. Fat chicks deserve that too."
相反，他说，有一次，当你喝醉时，你告诉我，“如果你向我求婚，别用男人通常对待胖女孩的那种狗屁方式——把它当成秘密，或者你只是想阻止我离开你。瘦女孩得到公开求婚，就像那些男人赢得了什么大奖一样。胖妞也值得那样。”
Our program was produced today by Susan Burton, Elna Baker. Our production staff-- Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Karen Duffin, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, Lyra Smith, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our editor's Joel Lovell. Editorial help from Julie Snyder. Research help from Christopher Swetala. Musical help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
我们的节目今天由苏珊·伯顿、埃尔娜·贝克制作。我们的制作人员——佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、尼尔·德拉明、凯伦·达芬、斯蒂芬妮·福、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、莱拉·史密斯、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。我们的编辑是乔尔·洛弗尔。来自朱莉·斯奈德的编辑帮助。来自克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉的研究帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life was delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he just loves a conference room. You know what I'm talking about-- the big table, the white board.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他就是喜欢会议室。你知道我在说什么——那张大桌子、白板。
[SIGH]
[叹气]
Chairs.
椅子。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - CHARLIE DORE, "BIG BONED GIRL"]
[音乐 - 查理·多尔，“骨架大的女孩”]